And finally, you can even
imagine switching from a full
screen activity to a dialog at 600dp.
Dialogs are often a good way
to maintain some context for
simpler detail screens, keeping part
of the previous screen visible, and
relieving some of the pressure to fill
up the screen with more information.
Since an activity's theme controls
whether or not it's shown as a dialogue,
we can switch between themes
using resource qualifiers.
Here's a quick example of some code for
that.
We have my MyTheme,
which inherits from BaseTheme.
And BaseTheme inherits from
the standard Theme.AppCompat, or
Theme.Material, or
whatever theme you want.
But for larger screens, we replace
the definition of base themes,
such that it inherits,
from Theme.AppCompat.Dialog.
The reason we don't just replace,
MyTheme, here is so
that we can put our theme
attributes in one place.
This kind of clever two
step theme inheritance
really helps minimize code overlap.
And another quick note here.
We use the smallest width, or sw
qualifier, instead of just the width, or
w qualifier.
This ensures that the value won't
change when you rotate the screen.
After all, it'd be a little weird if,
turning your
phone from portrait to landscape,
popped your screen into a dialog.
>> That was an introduction to some
of the standard things you can vary
in your UI to make better use of space.
This is by no means an exhaustive list.
The key is to work out when your UI no
longer works, at a certain size, or
when it breaks, and to make to changes
to adapt it to the available space.
Let's go to Nick to see some
examples of this in action.